Hello Freak bitches.
He did this movie.
A lot of people were viewed it from the moment we announced it.
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm going to make a movie with my daughter and giant depths in and his daughter
is going to be a two and right away I saw it like fucking the long sharp knives
come out and so as expected it goes to Sundance and you know,
so I'm not saying this movie is for everybody.
It's for like 10 people in the world,
but the 10 people that love it will love it.
Like religion.
Having you always done that though,
you just kind of do what you like to do is turn my life.
I could turn it around.
Turn on you.
What I like about what you do is you are,
you're very much an accepted inside guy who lives like some guy from Jersey who
was trying to break into the business.
Like this is useful because you never really understand how people professional
see you.
You know how the world sees you because they'll tell you they didn't give given
moment.
Joe,
Joe Normal or Sally and normal people will live in the real world and shit,
but your peers and people like we work in entertainment and shit.
Yeah.
How Mary,
you're very unaffected.
You're a uniquely unaffected Casa.
Like ineffective.
No,
you're very effective.
You're effective at doing what you enjoy and that's why you have such a unique
and loyal fan base is because they know they're,
it's like in this world,
there's not a whole lot of unique visions.
There's a lot of ideas.
They get brought to producers and executives and a bunch of people pile in and
it becomes more of a,
an idea where it's trying to appeal to a broader audience and it switches up and
then someone wants to bring it a love interest.
There's,
there's all sorts of influences that happen that homogenize as you drink some
milk.
I know.
That was my time is milk.
Oh my Lord.
That was perfect.
That's the perfect timing of a standup comic Logan.
Oh my.
It does really.
That's the best word for it because even though if it's good like you,
you,
you don't feel like that guy.
Like Tarantino is one of the unique guys where even though it was movies of
these gigantic mega blockbusters,
it feels like he's doing his own thing that feels like this crazy fucker just
got the money and the wheels and they're listening to him cause he's Tarantino.
You are movies at the same kind of connects with more people.
There's more of a like,
oh yeah,
that's cool.
It's cinema of cool because you could just look out it even if you don't have an
experiential connection to it.
Like,
oh I once went to a 50s cafe as per,
yeah,
you're just like,
that looks bad.
St John Travolta dancing.
We want to throw me.
That's bad as all the way it shapes everything about it.
It's just like cinema of cool and fed by a lifetime of movie loving and a movie
diet.
Yeah.
So if you love movies,
here's a God that distills everything.
That's the essence of Cool of cinema and I don't want to keep hitting the cool
Belks people like come on.
It's a hipster term,
but it,
it does distill it down to those moments.
Not so much like massive arcs,
but Ooh,
this feels awesome.
That's dope.
Oh,
that's metal.
Well,
yeah,
you have that same kind of thing.
You're your are very people comedies,
comedies in particular.
Like that was one of the more you in interesting and unique things about red
state because I had no,
you didn't tell me a word about it.
He said,
I don't want you to know nothing.
Just Colin's dry filthier than I met in me and me and Marin's sit there and
watched it and we're at the end of it.
We were like,
Holy Shit.
Like what the fuck was that?
He was crazy.
It wasn't a comedy at all.
Oh Wow.
Like throw them a curve and be like,
oh,
he's like,
we thought we saw everything.
Like I always felt most people saw him.
He was like,
oh,
he did clerks.
And then he's done about 96 variations.
People need to see red state.
If you haven't seen red state,
that is a,
it's,
I don't want to say too much cause I want people to go into it the way I went
into it.
Just go see that fucking movie.
But that's another movie where even though it wasn't like the same voice,
it was still a unique voice.
Right.
You know,
it's like,
I think,
I don't know what it's like to make a movie,
but it's gotta be,
the lot of people have a lot of say he nudges is bigger,
the budget
or you know,
you have to listen to a bunch more people and you can't be unreasonable about
it.
If you get him tremendous amounts of success like JJ Abrams and you're a nice
guy at the same time,
you know,
you can get away with being like,
I'm going to do whatever I want.
And people like what you want tends to work.
So here go nuts.
But generally speaking,
the more money you,
except the more input.
You also have to accept lower the budget.
And if it's coming out of your pocket,
you don't gotta say Shit to anybody or nobody could tell you anything.
But you know,
if you're putting together something small,
it's still a smaller circle of people.
It's kind of answered.
She didn't.
You always have to be willing to hear what they're saying.
If somebody is willing to give you ungodly of money and make pretend mind you,
this is not like,
I'm going to give you funds and you're going to give me eggs and I'm going to
sell those eggs and I'm gonna make more money selling those eggs.
They're like,
we're going to give you money and you're going to take this goofy fucking idea
you have and try to make it real and,
and turn it into a movie that may work or may not work.
It's all crap.
Shoot.
It's like buying a lottery ticket to a large degree,
no guarantees that the lever be an audience for it.
So I learned that midway my career and realize,
well,
just work for you.
Sounds masturbatory.
But it's like if you are the audience that you're trying to hit,
then you'll always be satisfied.
You know,
it's like if you want other people to like it,
it's subjective and it might not find that people dig what you're doing.
And you know,
if you're looking for monetary success,
good luck.
Nobody can guess that.
Like even when marvel releases a new movie and we know marvel is exceptional at
what they do,
put them in Pixar,
marvel,
Pixar on care of the best of the best.
Even when they release a movie,
they clench a little bit because they're like,
anything could happen,
anything could happen at all.
So generally speaking they're a little more insulated from like,
Oh shit,
we lost money.
It's actually those monies.
Those marvel movies are so expensive now because dude,
it's like the same thing with the animated movies.
The animated movies are ungodly expensive to make,
but they print money and they print money,
not just the first time they come at the box office.
They print money through all the licenses.
They print money where you know sometimes you go like they're doing a sequel to
that.
Why?
Why don't they do something new?
Because they've already built the world.
It's already there.
And a computer and they're like,
oh,
we need this new script and we're good.
We've done our infrastructure.
Like when you think about it,
if you were building something,
you built all this massive infrastructure and spent three years putting it
together and did it once and then you're like,
okay,
everybody goodbye forever.
It's kind of a waste of everything you put together.
That's why they immediately go for a sequel.
None.
Hey,
they know they're going to make money,
but B,
they're going to make more money because they don't have to invest as much time
and money as they did the first time.
So that's what makes a studio go like,
oh,
that's easier.
That's low hanging fruit and everyone's happy.
You know,
it's not like they're making art films that only few people,
like generally they tend to make flicks that a bunch of people want to go see.
And that riles up people that want to see newer films or something like that.
Cause like,
why is it always the same movie over and over again?
But you know,
I submit to you if you're going to see a superhero movie,
expect a little fucking sameness.
It's a story of like an exceptional being with powers that others don't,
and hopefully that person will use it for good.
You know,
you can only cut that cheese so many fucking times where,
and say it's something new.
I'll let you go.
I think the watchmen took it to a new place and I love the watching,
but at the end of the day,
it's just likes people in mass doing the right thing.
And yeah,
they fucked in space.
But other than that,
there was some people in mass trying to do the right thing.
They were murdered to the murder at each other.
Like is caught up in Batman v Superman.
I heard there were some murders in that movie in the movie.
I was like,
did they say somebody's fucking died in prison and over Batman?
You know,
they,
they went in a strange direction.
[inaudible].